there's one scene  in this film that was done only in one  take there's a wheelbarrow  that man was already unconscious i  wanted to get one in excuse me would it  be possible to remove me from the chair  no time we should definitely go  channing and brad i gotta give them all  the props all i ask is that you don't  drop me flip me run over me i just  didn't want to die action  to have brad pitt pushing a wheelbarrow  and then shaking that hair out while  explosions are happening is the thing  dreams are made of well i do this like  france where i'm running like i'm in an  aerobics class i had no idea that i was  gonna run like that until the moment  all i had to do was sit there channing  and brad had to do all the work  one take why are things exploding  [Music]  [Music]  you